[Musik]
jetzt live aus köln der presseclub mit
vor
herzlich willkommen schön sonntag aus
köln schön dass sie dabei sind heute
wird in deutschland gewählt und egal wie
es ausgeht angela merkel wird nach 16
jahren nicht erneut ins kanzleramt
einziehen das ist das ende einer ära
nicht nur für uns über vieles wurde im
wahlkampf gestritten und diskutiert aber
außenpolitik und internationales
spielten im wettstreit ums kanzleramt
kaum eine rolle und das obwohl kaum ein
land derart global verflochten und
abhängig ist wie unser
es geht nicht nur darum wer sich in
zukunft mit den mächtigen der welt
trifft wie wird sich das land unter
neuer regierung in den großen konflikten
dieser zeit positionieren die usa wollen
unter die beiden eigentlich wieder
verlässlicher sein haben frankreich aber
erst vor kurzem in einem rüstungsdeal
buchstäblich ausgebootet china ist
einerseits ein wichtiger handelspartner
verletzt aber gleichzeitig offenkundig
menschenrechte und fährt in der
außenpolitik eine aggressive strategie
europa muss zusammenhalten in diesem
punkt sind sich die aussichtsreichsten
kanzlerkandidaten einig es gibt paar
prinzipien die für uns wichtig sind zu
denen zählt die starke europäische union
wir müssen gemeinsame projekte beginnen
auch rüstungsprojekte beginnen um auch
einmal handeln zu können wenn die usa
sich zurückziehen doch auch der
zusammenhalt der eu wird durch
spannungen zwischen ost und west auf die
probe gestellt ganz egal wie es aussieht
das neue gesicht von deutschland in der
welt wer auf angela merkel folgt hat
viel zu tun
deutschlands rolle in der welt was kommt
nach merkel das ist heute unser thema
darüber wollen wir diskutieren dem
presseclub und das sind heute meine
gäste sabine fuß anno leitet das
auslandsmagazin die auslandsredaktion
des französischen wirtschaftsmagazin
star eric kirschbaum berichtet als
freier journalist für die los angeles
times aus berlin felix lee war für die
tageszeitung die tat sei als
korrespondent in peking und ist nun in
der taz zentrale für weltwirtschaft
zuständig und thomas mayer ist leitender
redakteur bei der in wien erscheinen
österreichischen tageszeitung der
standard er berichtet über die eu und
die nato aus brüssel seien sie alle
herzlich willkommen und noch ein hinweis
für sie liebe zuschauer via stream in
dieser sendung live in mehreren sozialen
netzwerken und freuen uns auch auf ihre
meinungen und fragen zu unserem heutigen
thema herr meier merkel hat in europa in
den 16 jahren ihrer kanzlerschaft viele
regierungschefs kommen und gehen
sie war die kontinuität und sicher auch
dadurch eine autorität in eu mit welchen
in der eu mit welchen erwartungen blick
brüssel heute auf berlin also auf der
einen seite ist das mit sicherheit ein
großer einschnitt es gibt keinen
regierungschef der nur annähernd so
lange im amt war wie angela merkel der
nächste niederländer mark rutte ich
glaube wenn der morgen zurücktreten
würde würde das im restlichen europa
kein beben auslösen aber wenn natürlich
die kanzlerin des größten
einflussreichsten und stärksten landes
abtritt und ein neuer kanzler kommt dann
sagt das natürlich für große erwartungen
ob es so weitergehen wie bisher oder ob
es neue anstöße gibt und wer der neue
mann oder die neue frau an der spitze
sein wird der diese politik machen wird
frano frankreich und deutschland gelten
ja immer so als motor europas die
franzosen wählen im nächsten jahr ihren
neuen präsidenten oder ihre präsidentin
was erwarten die franzosen von
deutschland nach der ära merkel oder
anders gefragt wenn marco in deutschland
werden könnte
ist schwer zu sagen er hat beide
kandidaten anfang september im
élyséepalast empfangen erst mal scholz
und dunham laschet 06 08
september und die berater von makro
sagen beide sind gleich beide sind sehr
europa orientiert und wir hatten in der
deutschen botschaft nach sechs und
september um 8 september einen
hintergrundgespräch mit den zwei
kandidaten auf deutsch also mit massen
und die zwei hatten die gleiche
botschaft also sie lieben europa sie
wollen deutsch französische
beziehungen weiter machen wie beim in
der merkel zeit und sie haben auch
gesagt sie wollen nicht das geld aus dem
fenster werk wegschmeißen also das ist
für ich denke eine botschaft in
frankreich und das letzte das sehr
interessant war beide haben gesagt dass
die europäische souveränität sehr
wichtig ist und das wort souveränität
hat jahrelang nicht gehörte nicht so
vokabel der deutsche politiker und jetzt
haben dass beide scholz und laschet
gesagt steht für europa genau und was
makronen fiel am herzen liegt also er
würde glaube ich mit beiden kandidaten
leicht arbeiten kein okay auf
souveränität für europa kommen wir im
verlaufen hätte mit sicherheit zurück
aber zunächst zeit versprochen an sie
die frage what do you bush barack obama
donald trump und jetzt joe biden merkel
hat mit vier us-präsidenten
zusammengearbeitet und ich glaube man
kann sagen das verhältnis war sehr
unterschiedlich eng zu obama zu kramp
sagen wir mal distanziert
mit welchen hoffnungen und befürchtungen
blicken die usa heute auf deutschland
und die wahl in erwartung dass es konnte
kontinuität gibt es deutschland
weiterhin eine super lässige partner
bleibt den nato und der westliche welt
und vor allem wir wissen alle diese
aufkommende spannungen mit china braucht
beiden braucht die usa ein ganz
zuverlässige partner hier in deutschland
und der eu das wird unterschätzt
manchmal und deutschland wie gefährlich
die situation in asien gewonnen sich aus
spannungen da gibt das geht nicht nur
wirtschaftsprobleme ist wirklich eine
sicherheitspolitische problemen beiden
braucht deutschland als anker in europa
als wichtige zuverlässiger partner für
die spannungen die demnächst kommen der
bundespräsident hat ja vor der un
versammlung in dieser woche am freitag
noch mal versichert dass deutschland
auch nach der wahl seine internationale
verantwortung
wahrnehmen wird dass er das für nötig
hielt sagt ja auch etwas aus und es gibt
einen eindruck den ich in der eingangs
moderation geschildert habe der aber
auch offenbar geteilt wird wir haben
einträge etwa bei twitter die sagen
weshalb spielt ein außen
sicherheitspolitik im wahlkampf kaum
eine rolle sind die deutschen zurzeit zu
sehr mit sich selbst beschäftigt auf
jeden fall also nicht hat das nahezu
schockiert muss ich sagen dass
außenpolitik
so gut wie gar keine rolle gespielt hat
von den kanzlerkandidaten aber auch von
den medien das muss man selbstkritisch
auch sagen also das bedingt sich ja auch
ne also
ich habe persönlich mal anfang mai eine
anfrage an frau berbalk gestellt um über
geopolitik über china usa und so zu
reden sie hatte sich ja am anfang ihrer
kanzlerkandidatur auch hat sie habe
ihren außenpolitischen schwerpunkt
betont dachte ich ist eine gute
gelegenheit sich dazu zu befragen sie
hatte das aus zeitlichen gründen
abgesagt und mir dann nur ein
schriftliches über in ihre pressestelle
mitgegeben was natürlich sehr
unbefriedigend ist aus journalistischer
sicht und dann kam tatsächlich auch in
meiner eigenen redaktionen die ansage
naja also mit außenpolitik lassen sich
keine wahlen gewinnen das mag zwar
durchaus so sein aber es ist ja die
aufgabe sowohl der politik als auch der
medien wichtige themen dann auch
entsprechend zu betonen und auch zum
thema zu machen und nicht danach zu
gehen was eventuell die mehrheit
interessieren würde also ich finde dass
ich kann da gehören kirschbaum da nur
zustimmen also in asien brodelt es
deutschland spielt eine ganz wesentliche
rolle nur ein ganz kurzer asbeck 90
prozent des deutschen außenhandels hat
in irgendeiner weise mit dem ausland
oder der wirtschaftsleistung hat mit dem
außenhandel zu tun und zu denken dieser
konflikt mit den usa und china das geht
uns hier in deutschland nicht an das ist
naiv blauäugig und da muss ich sagen
habe es hat sowohl die politik als auch
die medien haben da in der hinsicht in
diesem wahlkampf versagt
eine zahl wie man viel in paris also in
frankreich sagt es ist deutschland ein
prozent der weltbevölkerung und zehn
prozent der exporte in der ganzen welt
bleiben wir mal dabei diese diese
dominante wirtschaftliche stellung die
deutschland insbesondere auch als
bevölkerungsreichstes land innerhalb der
eu hat was bedeutet dass sie haben es
gesagt alle bekennen sich pro europäisch
alle drei kanzlerkandidat in bernburg
scholze flasche betonen wie
proeuropäisch sie eingestellt sind aber
mal konkret was
wird die künftige rolle deutschlands in
europa sein müssen was muss die nächste
bundesregierung dort leisten ich glaube
man kann es mit einem einfachen satz
beantworten die nächste deutsche
bundesregierung wird noch stärker noch
offensiver in europa auftreten müssen
man kann nicht als deutschland mit
dieser überragenden rolle ich kann den
kollegen lino zustimmen auch ich war
gerade schockiert davon dass man über
klimapolitik über sicherheitspolitik
reden kann über co2 bepreisung muss man
konkret zu machen ohne irgendeinen link
zu brüssel zum programm der europäischen
kommission zu machen alle diese großen
fragen auch migrationspolitik wir kommen
mit sicherheit noch zu anderen themen
die werden ja nicht in berlin
entschieden die werden in der
zwischenzeit zwischen den hauptstädten
berlin paris und anderen hauptstädten
und brüssel mit den gemeinschaftlichen
institutionen im parlament und der
kommission entschieden und das wäre
eigentlich das thema gewesen wie möchte
einerseits deutschland seine interessen
in brüssel wahrnehmen und was die die
kollegen angesprochen hat mit dem max
bruch von der souveränität europe damit
meint makro wir müssen als europäer
gemeinsam in der welt so auftreten nicht
also gerne ein staat aber es wäre würden
wir quasi auf augenhöhe mit den chinesen
mit den vereinigten staaten und so
weiter mit spiel und da hat merkel ja
das muss man sagen eigentlich sich sehr
passiv verhalten und das ist eine der
ganz wichtigen fragen die eigentlich in
fast allen ländern diskutiert wird und
diesbezüglich gibt es große erwartungen
und auch was den wahlkampf betrifft auch
enttäuschungen dass sich deutschland so
nach innen gekehrt und so passiv
präsentiert sie wird sehr kritisiert die
wähler merken in frankreich man sagt
dass sie die leiterin einer großen
schweiz war die business macht viel geld
viel überschüsse aber wenig politik und
jetzt müssen die deutschen politisch
erwachsen sein also ist der karikatur
löste ein bisschen was makro möchte als
jahr 2017 an den an die macht gekommen
ist da war ein ganz junger präsident der
war nicht mal 40 jahre alt und er hat
seine sabban rede gehalten
september 17 und er wollte unbedingt
dass merkel mit ihm die zusammenarbeit
auf der europäischen ebene vertieft und
dass ich schnell und viel tut und er hat
lange auf eine antwort gewartet war eine
enttäuschung und vielleicht ist jetzt
nach der korona krise nach dem
rettungspaket nach dem gemeinsamen
schulden die zeit was zusammen
weiterzumachen
sieht es für denkbar dass eine neue
bundesregierung wir wissen nicht wer sie
stellt aber wir kennen die die
vermutlich daran beteiligt sein werden
dass die abschied nimmt von dieser von
ihnen beschriebenen merkelschen politik
ich sag mal der etwas zurückhaltung
gegenüber etwa den forschen ansätzen
frankreich wir brauchen mehr europäische
souveränität wird sich das ändern ich
bin sogar überzeugt davon dass das der
fall sein wird ich kann das auch
begründen
man das anzuknüpfen die besucher von
scholz und laschet in harrys ich würde
sogar so weit gehen zu sagen insgeheime
wird das niemals öffentlich sagen
insgeheim wünscht sich der französische
präsident er stolz warum weil ich stolz
als finanzminister gezeigt hat dass er
in der ganzen fiskalpolitik in der
finanz und wirtschaftspolitik rund um
die eurozone viel mehr bereit ist mit
den franzosen gemeinsam zu gehen als
laschet und cdu/csu das bisher
angedeutet haben das ist ein ganz ganz
zentrales thema der zukunft und da wird
absolut erwartet dass die deutschen sich
öffnen in richtung der partner und nicht
so wie bisher es deutschland ag agieren
das haben wir auch gesehen in den
vergangenen jahren es ist vieles in
europa an baustellen offen unter anderem
auch deswegen weil der einflussreichste
staat auch merkel als kanzlerin hier
immer sehr sehr vorsichtig war um das
mit marco zu beantworten ich kann mich
noch sehr gut erinnern er hat ja dann
nach dieser bonn rede in aachen den
karlspreis bekommen die größten
europäischen preis und er hat eine
fulminante rede gehalten im ratssaal von
rachen und angela merkel war es eine
festrednerin und er hat sie direkt
angesprochen sagt angela wir dürfen
keine angst haben wir müssen rasch
handeln wir müssen weitergehen
verblüffende warum das auf die auf die
port zu bringen
merkel hat dann eine eine eine eine
antwort gegeben die verblüffen war so
sinngemäß ich bewundere ja diese
begeisterungsfähigkeit die dieser mann
hat es ist ein junger mann jetzt auf die
europäische bühne getreten für den der
euro und die um die union
selbstverständlich ist er war ja elf
oder zwölf jahre alt 1989 wie diese
ganzen umbrüche waren also er hat
gesprochen wie die oma über ihn endlich
ein bisschen das war ein sehr seltsam
ist sehr selbstbestimmung bringt das auf
den punkt was damit gemeint sein
europäische souveränität kirschbaum ist
das etwas was die usa auch von europa
erwarten wir blicken die usa darauf es
ist ja eine reaktion auch auf das
transatlantische verhältnis dass europa
den eindruck hat ganz so sicher können
wir uns auf die usa nicht mehr verlassen
in der vergangenheit ist und deswegen
müssen wir souveräner und autarker
werden auch in sicherheitsfragen ist das
eine sicht die aus amerikanischer aus
amerikanischer sicht begrüßt und die
männer begrüßen eine starke gruppe die
wollen eine starke europa starke partner
aber europa redet seit jahren über
dieses qualität die bei innovalight
starke verteidigung die haben
verteidigungssysteme mitteile die und
kompatibel ist sie geben viel geld für
beteiligung aus aber es sinnlos oft wie
meine fans sicherlich um diesen baum
geschichte später sprechen oder das ist
wirklich ein glänzendes beispiel was in
europa alles falsch lief und läuft und
war mir so probleme gibt europa braucht
eine starke usa wie die uhr sein starker
opel braucht die sohlen die usa will
dass die zusammen stark arbeiten und
dass die europäer stark sind weil es
gibt wie wir gesagt haben mit china
wirklich eine neue karte krieges da vor
der tour die deutschen merken das gar
nicht wie gefährlich das geworden ist
dass lassen uns darüber reden wir haben
die haben den deal angesprochen muss man
vielleicht kurz erläutern es gibt ein
abkommen der usa mit australien und den
vereinigten königreich strategische
allianz im pazifischen raum es war ein
modell geplant mit frankreich den hat
ein usa
milliarden sagen sie es
auf einmal werden die australier die u
boote nicht an frankreich kaufen aber an
amerika und ein bisschen an boris
johnson in england auch und natürlich
hat sich makro super aufgeregt also der
spielt auch viel nach in diesem
typischen französischen stil mit lyrik
und und große setzte aber er war sehr
empört hat es nicht gewusst dass der
dass sie das abbrechen würden und
natürlich ist es schwingt ein großer
anlass damit er sagen kann jetzt muss
europa zusammenhalten und wir müssen die
zusammenarbeit vertiefen aber er hat
gesagt es ist eindeutig im rücken weil
es war sehr sehr empört herrlich ich
will dass
sie weiter reichen aber
keinen eintrag aufnehmen aus dem
gästebuch
ein herr oder frau dass es nicht
erkennbar hoffmann schreibt dort die usa
scheinen ihren außenpolitischen focus
gerade stärker nach asien zu verlagern
wie begegnen in deutschland und die eu
dieser entwicklung das ist eigentlich
neu also dass die wittlicher das wurde
ja von der obama-administration
ausgerufen das war 2013 also wir reden
von vor acht jahren und europa
deutschland
hat verbal schon immer gesagt ja wir
müssen uns da auch mehr irgend diese
region beschäftigen es passierte aber
nichts und ich glaube um dann nochmal
auch auf die bilanz von frau merkel
zurück zu gehen also sie ist ja
überhaupt nicht dumm ich muss sagen ihre
hintergrundgespräche sie hat ja in
meiner zeit als korrespondent in peking
war hat die fast jährlich peking besucht
und sich das waren die highlights ihre
hintergrundgespräche weil sie so
unglaublich klug und durchdacht und
wissen die weltlage beschrieben hat und
man wunderte sich dann immer dass sie
ganz ganz viele welt konflikte und es
gibt ja auch niemanden anderen der der
eine der der so erfahren ist in der
weltpolitik wie es frau merkel ist und
dann wundert man sich immer wenn sie
dann zurückgehen dass davon immer
anscheinend in ihrem handeln sich nichts
widerspiegelt deswegen ich bin mir auch
nicht so sicher also ich glaube schon
dass jetzt mit einer neuen
bundesregierung wie immer sie auch
aussieht wird sich einiges ändern würde
ich bin mir aber nicht sicher ob das
unbedingt zum positiven ist weil das
wissen das hat frau merkel durchaus
mitgebracht was frau merkel fehlte das
war oder weiß ich nicht ob sie er hatte
aber sie hat die zumindest nie
formuliert mal eine vision zu
formulieren wo sieht sie denn
deutschland europa in der weltpolitik in
fünf jahren oder in zehn jahren und
ehrlich gesagt so wie ich den wahlkampf
jetzt erlebt habe habe ich das von
keinem dieser katzer kandidaten auch
gehört also sie sagen okay härtere hand
mit china und so weiter wir müssen
eigenständiger sein usw das hat aber
frau merkel irgendwie mehr oder weniger
auch schon immer alles gesagt wie sich
das in konkretes handeln umsetzt davon
kam nichts und insofern benutzer während
er ist das ist genau das problem merkel
jedes jahr in china merkel mag die
torlauf lief in deutschland betrachtet
chinas wirtschaftlicher und diese ganze
ups kann das kann man ganz gut sehen es
ist nicht alles sofort ausgetauscht wird
peugeot jetzt die mechanische u-boote
nukleare boten die können drei monaten
unter wasser bleiben die französische
sind diese rebellen nach 20.30 da kann
die sind doppelt so teuer wie jetzt beim
spucken fotografen es ist wirklich eine
sicherheitsfrage nicht deine
wirtschaftsraum europa hier über die
wirtschaftliche aspekte die austrian
haben angst vor china die wo
dies möglich gibt die amerikaner betrags
an sicherheitsfragen politischer
geostrategische und nicht wirtschaft und
jugendgruppen wenn ich die presse lese
es ist ob das tholi dem rk die
eintracht
da widersprechen weil ich glaube ich
nicht richtig ist und ich würde das
verstärken was der kollege lee gesagt
hat es hat ja in southhampton im vor dem
sommer einen g 7 gipfel gegeben und da
gab es ein treffen zwischen mit den
briten amerikaner australier und da sind
genau diese dinge besprochen worden und
das kam sogar in der schlusserklärung
den fußnoten vor was hier offenbar
passiert ist und das ist kein zufall und
da hingehe ich ein bisschen tiefer noch
in dieses problem hinein dass das da
steckt auch ein bisschen tragödie merkel
ihnen sozusagen global oder oder
außenpolitisch die europäer haben das
offenbar falsch gelesen und nur deswegen
konnten sie überrascht sein dass das
tatsächlich passiert ich habe gestern
oder vorgestern gelesen ich glaube der
council on foreign relations hat eine
umfrage publiziert
wie denn die deutschen diese krise
einschätzen diese region und
die ganz große mehrheit der deutschen
ist der meinung dieser bereich
indopazifischen raum das ist ein
amerikanisches problem das hat mit uns
nichts zu tun kann uns auch nicht
wirklich überraschen wenn wir
zurückdenken was nur sechs wochen in
afghanistan passiert ist das ist ja
eigentlich ganz verblüffend ich wirklich
mag die europäer außen und
sicherheitspolitisch sich präsentieren
und dann auch immer wieder überrascht
sind dass die welt ganz anders läuft als
sie sich das vorstellen wir waren an
einem wichtigen punkt da will ich
nochmal in die runde geben deutsche
außenpolitik damit auch sehr stark
europäische im umgang mit china stark
fokussiert auf wirtschaftliche er gleich
auch noch versuchen investitionsabkommen
die haut von der wirtschaft
durchzusetzen das stichwort auto
außenwirtschaft
hat man das mit neid und bewunderung
gelesen aber wird es eine künftige
bundesregierung durchhalten können
diesen kurs fortzusetzen sehr stark auf
die wirtschaftlichen vorteile im umgang
mit china zu setzen aber das was die
amerikanischen besorgnisse sind nicht
aufzugreifen ich habe dazu auch ein
eintrag auf twitter michael zimmermann
fragt wie kann man als usa einen
verlässlichen partner erwarten das geht
dann wiederum in die richtung usa wenn
man selber nicht verlässlich ist das
zieht wahrscheinlich ein bisschen auf ja
wie afghanistan aber diese ist ist da
der spaltpilz im transatlantischen
verhältnis im umgang mit china also ich
glaube
das was merkel letztendlich die meiste
zeit ihrer amtszeit im umgang mit china
sehr erfolgreich war nämlich
wirtschaftspolitik außen nach vorne zu
stellen durchaus als verlässlicher
partner china aus chinesischer sicht
dann auch mal kritische themen
anzusprechen davon die anderen sprungs
chef auf europa ja teil zum großen teil
nicht mehr getan also menschenrechte
hinter verschlossenen türen stille
diplomatie das hat sie alles sehr gut
geschult und geschickt gemacht aber
immer weniger und ich glaube das große
versagen
dann letztendlich das was in den letzten
zwei drei jahren in china passierte
nämlich dass es da ein immer autoritärer
herrscher war der
immer selbstbewusst aber das land
insgesamt selbstbewusster das durchaus
erfolgreich durch viel erfolgreicher
durch die pandemie gegangen ist und was
das selbstbewusstsein noch mal gestärkt
hat und frau merkel in der zeit nicht
erkannt hat dass es dieses
weiterwurschteln immer nur schwer auf
fokus auf wirtschaftspolitik dass das
nicht funktioniert zumal china
technologischer auch
rapide aufgeholt hat und in naher
zukunft wahrscheinlich sogar auch
irgendwann mal die usa mal in naher
zukunft übertrumpfen wird und all das zu
denken ja deutschland kann mal ein
bisschen mit den amerikanern machen für
wirtschaft mit china und so weiter und
sich so durch vorstellen dass jetzt auch
selbst die beiden administrationen
verlangt deutsche firmen ihr müsst euch
entscheiden und das dann letztendlich
dann auch dazu führt dass deutsche
unternehmen dann sich mehr oder weniger
nimmermehr ihre produktionsstätte dann
entweder vor ort nach china oder in die
usa schicken so dass die
wertschöpfungskette dann auch nicht mal
hier zu lange stattfindet und dann auch
hier arbeitsplätze abgebaut werden also
all diese entwicklung die hat frau
merkel ist sie in diesen letzten zwei
jahren nicht angegangen und ich glaube
deswegen wird ein weiter so wie bisher
in der china politik in der deutschland
china politik sowieso nicht mehr von
deutschland muss ich entscheiden wie das
in einem punkte insgesamt jetzt sendet
mich da ich habe mal denn schon lange
her mit dem früheren französischen
staatspräsidenten carla ist ein
interview gemacht und er hat mir viel
erzählt über wir mit helmut schmidt
damals wie das alles entstanden ist
diese diese strategien der gemeinsamen
währung der aussenwirtschaftspolitik der
union und so weiter und er hat gesagt
wissen sie sie können keine keinen
außenhandel in der welt betreiben wenn
sie nicht gleichzeitig eine außen-
wirtschafts- und sicherheitspolitik
machen und das ist der entscheidende
punkt und er hat das mit dem bild
ergänzt das wäre als würde man eine
sinfonie spielen wollen ohne orchester
und das ist im moment glaube ich die die
europäische situation
wir müssen auch in erinnerung rufen dass
großbritannien ja ausgetreten ist ein
ganz wichtiger partner innerhalb der
nato das heißt ich denke wir sind wenn
man das jetzt auf eine höhere ebene
schraubt im moment in europa in einer
situation wo wichtige entscheidung
fallen muss wie wollen wir als europäer
sicherheitspolitisch eigentlich
weitermachen ohne briten die ganz
offensichtlich mit den amerikanern in
asien eine neue globale rolle suchen die
sind fallen also für uns europäer ein
gewisser weise aus und ich glaube dass
da die entscheidungen fallen werden vor
allem zwischen deutschen und frankreich
als leading nations gemeinsam
miteinander europäern das glaube ich
beschreibt sehr gute situation und das
kann man nicht nur wie merkel über die
wirtschaft machen das ist undenkbar aber
man hat gefragt ob die amerikaner zu
wollen ist deutschland ein super dass
sie gebaut und deutschland hat vor zehn
jahren versprochen 2% inlandsprodukt
verteidigung ließen bei 1,54 zu also die
werden es 2030 vielleicht erreichen
vielleicht nicht ja und das ist ein witz
ja der zweitgrößte nato partner und die
haben keine funkgeräte hier aus den
siebziger jahren war die wo sie wollen
dass ich investiere die haben u boote
die nicht fahrvereins segel die haben
flugzeuge die nicht weniger schulschiff
und dann gibt es leute in der spd wie
helmut dennig und die wollen keine keine
das nicht ausgeben die wohnung keine
amerikanische flugzeuge im team holen
kein nuklearer teilhaben denn wenn
deutschland die marke hier nicht haben
wollen das soll das sagen ich meine die
märkte sind hier nicht aus jux und
dollerei diesen hier um eine gemeinsame
beteiligung und wenn eine neue regierung
konnte das nicht charme würden dann dann
können können herr zimmermann mit den
amerikanern über
super lässiger paar gewesen was sie
sagen ist die usa sind zutiefst
enttäuscht von europa und insbesondere
von deutschland die promi das westtor
auszumachen aber deutschland so seine
verteidigung verpflichtungen
versprechungen nachkommen kann das so
wir gehören jetzt aber die geben weniger
geld aus weil es zwei prozent des
picknicks und wir sind 2,1 prozent das
bruttoinlandsprodukt und die deutschen
15 aber das ist mehr geld aber sie haben
versprochen 2 prozent theo waigel hat
immer gesagt 3,00 und jetzt mal die
deutschen zweier ausgeben so hinterher
dann gilt das weiß nicht vielleicht mal
kurz das bild bei wem wir wissen ja
nicht wie es ausgeht und das wollen wir
auch nicht antizipieren das müssen wir
heute abend aber
wie positionieren sich denn die
spitzenkandidaten mit wem wäre denn das
zwei prozent ziel am wahrscheinlichsten
erreichbar kann man das also aus meiner
sicht ist das mit laschet
wahrscheinlicher es hängt ganz davon ab
es liegt ja nicht an der person des
künftigen kanzlers es liegt an der
künftigen koalition also wenn das ein
links grünes bündnis ist beispielsweise
mit duldung der linkspartei dann kann
man sich kaum vorstellen dass
deutschland seine verteidigungsausgaben
deutlich anheben wird wenn das eine
koalition ist bei der die fdp beteiligt
ist schaut dass wieder ein bisschen
anders aus aber ich glaube cdu fdp das
würde wahrscheinlich eher höher gehen
wobei man muss man das doch nur ein satz
noch ich kann das noch ergänzen auch
dieses bild durch zahlen es hat der
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg vor
kurzem die die beitrags zahlen bekannt
gegeben deutschland ist nur deswegen auf
157 prozent hochgeschnellt weil es im
jahr 2020 in der krone akademie einen
extrem im wirtschaftsabschwung relativ
schon nächstes jahr werden die
verteilungs ausgaben wieder auf ich
glaube 1,7 und 30 prozent sinken
frankreich in der tat hat erstmalig
jetzt seit langer zeit die zwei prozent
schwelle überschritten also auch da
sieht man geht es eher auseinander als
das ist hier in europäisch sozusagen
konvergent wird und die staaten sich
daran nähren stadt dass sie sich
entfernen und eine kurze ergänzung als
ich meine die haben natürlich recht mit
unter rot-grün wird das noch
unwahrscheinlicher aber man muss einfach
bedenken 16 jahre hat jetzt schwarz
regiert und da ist ja absolut ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht viel gekommen es geht
ja auch nicht darum jetzt die amerikaner
irgendwie zu erfreuen oder irgendwelche
versprechen einzulösen sondern es war
jetzt letztendlich ja auch die trump
jahre die ihr uns ja alle gelehrt hat
nein es sind nicht die gleichen
interessen die die europäer haben und
die amerikaner gerade mit blick auf
asien und so weiter und da sei wäre es
zumindest sinnvoll ob man jetzt mit den
amtlichen anderer meinung sind die
unterschiede bei den interessen es gibt
viele unterschiedliche
wirtschaftsinteressen also
die usa ist nicht in der größe oder von
in diesem ausmaß abhängig technologisch
wirtschaftlich von china wies
deutschland ist im außenhandel alleine
das unterscheidet sich schon die usa
haben natürlich noch mal ganz eigene
interessen dann auch wie sieht dann im
pazifischen raum dann agieren wollen
welche handelswege sie sichern wollen
sie verhalten sich jetzt ja nicht
unbedingt als die großen
friedensstifters muss ich zu
dazu sagen die europäer verhalten sich
halt gar nicht es geht ja darum dass die
europäer überhaupt sich erstmal mal eine
gemeinsame strategie überlegen und sich
nicht so leicht auseinander dividieren
lassen wie das china durchaus im zuge
der zerstrittenheit innerhalb der eu
erfolgreich getan hat weil ich glaube es
gibt es gilt ja und das ist die zweite
grosse aspekt der ja völlig in diesem
wahlkampf verloren gegangen ist wo
stattdessen über ich sag mal
nebenschauplätze wahnsinnig gestritten
wird das wird über zwischenmieter
befeuert sei es über gender stern tieren
über über masken tragen über die impf
frage wird ideologisiert aber eins der
wichtigsten thema aus deutscher sicht
der multilateralismus der sich seit
jahren weltweit im abbau befindet wovon
deutschland so extrem profitiert hat der
ist ernsthaft in gefahr weil nationale
egoismen wieder überhand nehmen in
deutschland denken wir machen dann
einfach das mit was die usa oder was
china auch macht das wird nicht
funktionieren weil deutschland ist da
einfach dann doch zu klein und wenn
europa in eine kleinstaaterei zerfällt
dann wird deutschland und europa
überhaupt nicht mehr ernst genommen und
ich befürchte schon dass das inzwischen
sogar teilweise der fall ist das würde
ich gern wird aber gern noch mal mit
einer einer frage verbinden kirschbaum
hat vorhin gesagt die europäer gehen ja
durchaus viel für verteidigung aus aber
es ist unwirksam weil es verpufft und
weil es unterschiedliche waffensysteme
sind kann man mit zahlen alles belegen
strategische souveränität
antwort auf das was auch liegerad gesagt
hat um sozusagen auch ein stückchen
unabhängige eigenständige hans-hermann
zwischen was heißt das konkret was heißt
es etwa in der verteidigungspolitik muss
dort viel mehr passieren viel mehr
militärische integration vielleicht
sogar eine europäische armeen genau und
viel mehr geld und es ist auf dem weg
aber lange war es tabu in deutschland
und was herr lee sagt umher so
verheerend dass
außenpolitik nicht in der debatte waren
den tränen das zeigt dass die kandidaten
vielleicht angst vor diesem thema haben
und machen seit der hat europäische
reden also in vier jahren hat er vier
oder fünf und reden gehalten große
europäische reden frau merkel einmal in
16 jahren in brügge 2013 aber seine
leider ist immer zu sagen wir müssen ja
sagt er erwachsen sein wir müssen geld
zusammenbringen und
zusammen entscheiden und wir können
nicht uns nicht mehr auf die usa
verlassen ich nicht da ja nicht das
aufgreifen darf es hat nicht wirklich
verblüfft muss ich sagen diese träge und
diese innerdeutsche debatte und ich sage
meinen namen und sie werden sofort
verstehen was mich verblüfft hat und der
name ist ursula von der leyen wir haben
zum ersten mal seit 50 jahren eine eine
deutsche an der spitze der eu kommission
wenn sie die die rede von von der leyen
im europäischen parlament vor zwei
wochen nachlesen dann werden sie sehen
dass dort die europäische
verteidigungspolitik genau das was die
kolleginnen es geschildert hat ein
kernstück einnimmt der politik die sie
die sie in den nächsten jahren machen
möchte sie hat angekündigt es wird in
paris im nächsten jahr einen eigenen
verteidigungs gipfel geben auf der
höchsten ebene also dass so was in
deutschland überhaupt nicht mal erwähnt
wird dass die eigene also es ist ja
nicht die eigene kommissionspräsidentin
aber aber es ist zumindest eine deutsche
eine eine anspielstation die noch dazu
mal verteidigungsministerin gewesen war
jetzt weiß ich schon das ist da offenbar
viele innerdeutsche konflikte gibt darum
aber das ist dann doch verblüffend und
und das zeigt auch ich habe mal
geschrieben das sind langweilige
kandidaten und ein ende ein sehr
inhaltslose wahlkampf also bei allem
respekt wenn mietpreis deckel und
mindestlohn die wichtigsten themen sind
die deutschland im moment hat dann darf
man sich nicht wundern dass viele
partnerstaaten vor allem die mächtigen
partnerstaaten sich ein bisschen wundern
und sagen was ist in diesem land endlich
los nein stimmen wenn man über
verteidigung außenpolitik spricht in
deutschland war sagt man immer wieder
werden in der sängerin politisch
gewonnen oder verloren aber ich weiß es
nicht aber ich möchte noch zu einem
anderen aspekt kommen die mir noch nur
gestreift haben der französische robinho
hat geschrieben scholz wäre gut für die
finanzen aus französischer sicht und
schlecht für die verteidigung laschet
gut für verteidigung und schlecht für
finanzen lassen sie uns über das
geldwesen wir haben wir haben ein europa
das noch in der pandemie ist aber mit
schweren wirtschaftlichen belastungen
durch die pandemie wie die usa auch was
erwartet europa von der größten
wirtschaftsmacht
innerhalb der eu um aus der pandemie
wirtschaftlich wieder herauszukommen
also ich muss sagen
paris ist sehr erleichtert worden makro
mai 2020 als er mit angela merkel einen
gemeinsamen rettungsplan
gemeinsamen aufbau programmen und
gemeinsame schulden
frau merkel dazu gesagt hat das war das
und thieme tabu also für uns franzosen
haben wir immer gesagt wieso wollen die
deutschen keine gemeinsamen schulden so
kommen wir aus der krise schneller und
es war immer nein nein nein zurzeit von
wolfgang schäuble der was also die total
rote linie und auf einmal hat frau
merkel ja gesagt sie hat zwar gesagt
gemeinsame schulden nur einmal bezahlt
und allen ja genau aber marko hat gesagt
sie ich habe schon den fuß in der tür
ich habe es die tür ein bisschen
aufgemacht die werde ich total auf
machen also so ist ihre prognose die tür
wieder zu naja es war ja letztendlich
ein fehler ein geständnis für die
verfehlte europapolitik der 2013 14
jahre also wo ich irgendwo deutschland
da komplett gebremst hat und es ja so
weit geführt hat dass immer diesen druck
auf die südeuropäischen länder
griechenland
ihr müsst privatisieren junges
privatisieren dann wird der größte
mittelmeerhafen im östlichen mittelmeer
piräus an die chinesen verkauft und dann
weiter sich ja mal groß also ich glaube
all das waren ja riesen gigantische
fehler auch strategisch die deutschen
verursacht haben und ich glaube daran
davon hat man gelernt auch wenn man das
jetzt offiziell so nicht zugibt aber ich
glaube das war das schuldeingeständnis
und ich glaube zumindest wenn es nicht
solche ich sage jetzt mal altbackenen
völlig in den 90er jahren verharrten
politiker wie friedrich merz in einer
weise wieder eine wichtige rolle spielt
das glaube ich alle anderen davon
gelernt haben und es nicht mehr
zumindest nicht mehr in dieser vehemenz
zurückdrehen wollen wie sieht das bei
der euro-krise 2013 getan und herr
scholz hat von bazooka gesprochen ja
wenn du kein franzose gegen träumt und
ein zeichen auch wenn es schon viel an
merkel kritisiert und der regierung in
diesem fall muss man tatsächlich sagen
das war sehr gut dass sie das eingesehen
hat dass sie dann nachgegeben hat
man muss allerdings gleichzeitig auch
wieder präzisieren warum hat sie
nachgegeben nicht weil sie plötzlich
ihre harte euro position verlassen hat
sondern wir müssen zurück erinnern
damals in spanien in italien eine ganz
dramatische situation man dachte sich
wenn das mit corona eskaliert weiter ist
noch weiter eskaliert dann brechen diese
staaten möglicherweise weg wählen würde
das am allermeisten treffen deutschland
wir leben im binnenmarkt die leben einer
währungsunion also das war schon auch in
einem gewissen eigeninteresse dass man
dieses programm wieder auf vorbeugung
gemacht hat ich würde auch noch eine
begriffe ein bisschen korrigieren das
sind keine gemeinsamen schulden dass sie
nicht schulden für die deutschland
insgesamt haftet jedes land hafte nur
für den anteil der ihm vom
verteilungsschlüssel dazu stehen würde
wir sind gemeinschaftliche schulden die
auch die eu als als gemeinschaft
aufnimmt und auch wieder zurückbezahlt
durch klima abgaben aber in letzten
symbol her dass ja richtig dabei aber
einen letzten gedanken noch der
wichtiger scheint ich meine wir sind es
20 jahre nach einführung der
währungsunion es ist hoch an der zeit
dass man in deutschland endlich versteht
dass europa eigentlich weswegen
funktioniert weil nur die deutschen so
toll sind und alle anderen das ist ein
relativ sozusagen schulden der länder
sind nein es ist eine große europäische
volkswirtschaft und wir müssen uns
irgendwann entscheiden wollen wir auch
eine gemeinsame fiskalpolitik machen
thema klima steuern wie wollen sie denn
das klima retten wenn sie nicht auf
europäischer ebene gemeinsam co2 abgaben
klima steuern und so weiter koordiniert
einheben das kann ja nicht funktionieren
im wirtschaften die so eng miteinander
verbunden sind und dass diese themen in
deutschland nicht diskutiert werden das
ist ganz trefflich ein letzter satz ich
glaube es ist letztendlich die folge von
merklichen ich sage bewusst so
einschläferung politik es wird nie
heftig diskutiert und am ende ist alles
immer alternativen herr meier ist es
immer ein bisschen fazit zu ziehen also
höre ich raus in der rhone große
einigkeit nach merkel mehr engagement
deutschlands in europa sowohl in
sicherheit wie auch außenpolitischen
fragen auch in wirtschaftsfragen wird
gerne noch mal zu einem thema springen
sie gespannt
die andere gar nicht über russland
gesprochen eine große strategische frage
die die usa beschäftigen china die
größte zurzeit nach allen äußerungen der
politisch verantwortlichen aber
deutschland spielt auch im verhältnis zu
russland eine besondere rolle und auch
hier gibt es zahlreiche konflikte muss
ich nicht aufziehen und keine creme
annexion bombast
riem 2 was wäre denn die erwartungen der
usa in sachen russland an eine künftige
deutsche bundesregierung ja ich meine
außerdem zweimal merkel wirklich eine
sehr starke
verbündete der amerikaner gegenüber
russland das ist die hoffnung dass es so
weitergeht biden hat überraschend
0 2 durch schminken lassen aber
wahrscheinlich mit vielen versprechungen
vor deutschland ukraine nicht im stich
zu lassen aber extreme 2 wird weiterhin
ein problem für die eu sein aber
deutschland war wirklich merken
vielleicht meine russische kenntnisse
dass die puten seit 16 jahren gut kennt
merkel war wirklich ein
ein bollwerk in westen gegenüber wissen
und natürlich meine allererste den
problemen bei ya gespaltenes verhältnis
zu forte wasser mit spd und linken wenn
die an die markt käme die in washington
wird man hellhörig dann das linke
politik da man muss in der wische
russland freundliche politik ja aber was
dann es gibt immer noch sanktionen in
der eu wie wie geht damit warum deswegen
besonders spannende frage russland aber
die frage ist die hoffnung ist dass
deutschland weiterhin eine ganz wichtige
ganz klare linie hat das mit der krim
das geht gar nicht und also kontinuität
an einer stelle willkommen in die
schlussrunde unseres presseclubs und die
schlussfrage an sie alle würde ich gerne
jemandem überlassen der sie auf twitter
gestellt hat mister mienen der sich
welchen kanzler oder welcher kanzler den
traut die runde eine außenpolitik zu die
den zeiten im jahre 2021 folgenden
gerecht wird
jetzt jetzt dürfen sie wie also kann mit
ihnen kurze antworten kurze antworten
also ich bin überhaupt nicht begeistert
von allen das ist glaube ich deutlich
geworden aber ich glaube schon dass
annalena baerbock dann doch für eine
konsequente oder neu aus politik stehen
würde weil sie zumindest die berater auf
ihn so lange an da nicht mehr dran sie
dürfen es nur in einem satz sagen ich
habe den eindruck dass scholz
auch klare antwort meyer ich glaube dass
scholz und laschet beide es könnten bei
der burg die noch nie aus musik gemacht
hat dann habe ich dann meine ich bin
frage ich bin journalist ich wollte kann
wir sind am ende der sendung angelangt
dank an meine gäste für diese diskussion
dass liebe zuschauer war der presseclub
ihr im ersten wir freuen uns wenn sie in
den sozialen netzwerken weiter mit uns
diskutieren würden etwa beim presseclub
twitter-account hier geht es jetzt mit
den weiter mit dem europamagazin und zum
abschluss gibt es von mir noch zwei
wahlempfehlungen gleich erstens wenn sie
noch nicht gewählt haben dann gehen sie
hin nutzen sie ihre stimme und zweitens
schalten sie ein hier im ersten ab 17
uhr 15 die sendung zum ausgang der
heutigen bundestagswahl und im
presseclub nachgefragt den gibt es jetzt
wie immer auf phoenix und dem radio auf
wdr 5 danke für ihr interesse schönen
sonntag noch und schießen
[Musik]
willkommen zurück ich begrüße sie zum
presseclub nachgefragt hier auf phoenix
und im radio auf wdr5 deutschlands rolle
in der welt was kommt nach merkel das
ist das thema unserer runde hier im
presseclub und jetzt sind sie dran mit
ihren fragen an meine gäste und wir
gehen zunächst nach wildberg das liegt
bei stuttgart und dort ist benjamin
miano am telefon fabiano seien sie
gegrüßt hallo ich
auch willi gewundert dass wir den ganzen
tree allen europäische schuldenpolitik
und die außenpolitik deutschland nicht
brauchen wurde und die kanzlerkandidaten
formsache haben daher deutlich
unterschiedliche positionen was
gemeinschaft nicht in der eu angehen und
für mich ist es eigentlich auch ein
unding dass das nicht gebrauchen für wir
reden über steuererhöhungen dieser
erhöhung des renteneintrittsalters und
wir haben die höchste steuer und
abgabenlast wo ich die gleichen
deutschland
andere länder haben höhere
privatvermögen in der eu und wir sollten
mit unseren höheren steuer andere
ländern mit subventionieren und
mitfinanzieren und diese frage werde ich
nicht im wahlkampf wichtig gewesen und
ich frag mich warum die medien so eine
frage nie gestellt haben
wer möchte ich möchte gerne aber guten
tag herr miano von einer französischen
sicht jetzt
es hat nach der korona krise diesen
rettungsplan die sich gemeinsamen
schulden gegeben und anscheinend werden
unsere wirtschaften in ganz europa nach
zwei jahren wieder
nachgeholt haben dem niveau von vor 2009
10 wenn man zurück zur finanzkrise 2008
geht hat es zehn jahre gedauert also
vielleicht ist es eine antwort an ihrer
frage
ich möchte gerne eine kleine
korrigierend auch wir haben ja auch noch
nichts zu korrigieren sondern den den
anrufer er hat gesagt wir haben ja so
hohe steuerlast und wir sollen jetzt für
die anderen mitfinanzieren dieses bild
ist ein beliebter narrativ in
deutschland er stimmt nur leider nicht
es zahlt jedes eu-land und euro
rettungsschirm ist ein gutes beispiel
nur genau die beiträge die seiner größe
und seiner wirtschaftskraft entspricht
also erst zahlen auch beispielsweise die
slowakei oder griechenland selber oder
italien ein in diese gemeinsamen töpfe
die dann verteilt werden je nachdem wo
sie gebraucht werden das ist ein
gefährliches sind aber tief weil es
eigentlich immer dieses bild verstärkt
wir deutschen zahlen europa und das
stimmt nicht es ist eigentlich umgekehrt
deutschland sowie alle auch österreich
übrigens länder im zentrum europas
profitieren enorm von diesem gemeinsamen
europa und vom austausch im handel mit
osteuropa vor allem auch wenn gehen nach
außen schön albern
dort ist an zöllner am telefon herr
zöllner seien sie gegrüßt und ihre
anmerkung unserer diskussion wir sind
gespannt
meine frage glauben sie wirklich
toll branche tatsächlich das format
haben inhalten geben das zu vollbringen
wo ein paar merkel gescheitert ist sich
zum beispiel insbesondere bush gegenüber
schwierigen mitglieder wie polen oder
ungarn bekanntlich gab das prinzip
pflegen nehmen das reden geben
danke schön herr zöllner wer liebt ich
glaube ja weil da merkel einfach keine
gute rolle gespielt hat also es da geht
es ja nicht darum um das auftreten oder
wie
charmant oder seriös jemand auftritt
sondern es geht ja darum vor allem dann
auch taktisch zu gucken mit welchen
ländern man gewisse punkte durchsetzen
kann und da gab es ja durchaus den
vorstoß von makro da in vielen zentralen
fragen nicht zuletzt auch im umgang mit
china da auch eine gemeinsame
europäische strategie zu kommen und es
war frau merkel die das blockiert hat
mehr oder weniger also insofern ich
glaube wenn entweder herr laschet oder
herr scholz dieses problem erkennt dann
fällt es nicht wird es nicht schwer
fallen genau eine soll ein solches
bündnis oder eine solche zusammenarbeit
dann doch auch intensiver zu betreiben
weil von merkel kam daher einfach dazu
würde ich gern ein eintrag auf twitter
zu wort kommen lassen hauke cooper fragt
wie sollen wir die europäische
integration vorantreiben wenn wir jetzt
schon keinerlei handhabe gegen die
rechtsextremen reaktionären regierung in
polen und ungarn haben über die aber
noch gar nicht gesprochen da geht ja
auch ein riss durch europa wer möchte
kann gerne wenn sie wollen
ergänzt fang an ist tresor in die an der
grenze dann
also ich glaube dass allmählich alle
west länder die
verstehen wie wichtig das ist dass
dieses und orit ehre denken sowie ein
krebs sich in ganz europa verbreitet
marco hat im letzten rat von kultur
kampf gesprochen und merkel war sie
waren sich eigentlich haben wenig getan
aber es ist jetzt so dass wenn ganz
schrecklich gesetze
entschieden werden zum beispiel in
ungarn
was überhaupt so gegen
entschieden worden ist dass man da
angreifen kann mit dem portmonee dass
die dann diese länder weniger geld von
der eu bekommen das wird man besser
verstehen als eine politische lektion
wir gehen nach frankfurt am main dort
ist mirko nuhanovic am telefon ja hallo
seien sie gegrüßt und sie sind dran
den kirschbaum und zwar
eine stärkere deutschen führungsrolle
eigenständigkeit und so weiter wie er
sagt dann in einklang bringt wenn
deutschland seine eigenständigkeit zeigt
und auf eigenen treffer zu bilden dort
sind vorbei dazu sofort mit aktionen und
der regel kommen will dann zusammen
eindruck die usa wollen deutschland
haben aber das sage deutschland genau
das macht das die usa möchte
also ich würde gerne mal andere auch
haben so ist das ein bisschen quatsch
ist es die usa freut sich dass
deutschland eine starke rolle eine
führungsrolle spielt hier in europa das
wird man auf jeden fall live stream 2
ist nicht nur von den amerikanern
kritisiert wurden sondern ich franzosen
pro reli ganz europäer es war nicht nur
die usa das war eine breite masse und
die usa freut sich das dauert schon ein
starker führungsrolle übernommen hat
seit der wiedervereinigung ein advokat
für viele länder in osteuropa das freut
man sich natürlich sind die usa in
deutschland konkurrenten in
wirtschaftlich gebieten aber beiden die
regierung die denken wirklich erst in
ihre
sicherheitsfragen geopolitische frage
und deutschland ist unheimlich wichtig
und wie das sage ich immer wieder
deutschland der zweitgrößte
nato-mitglieder deswegen ist ein starkes
deutschland ein starker wird herr
beitragen durch eine vorbildfunktion aus
deutschland ist unheimlich wichtig und
es fehlt
presseclub kommt nach köln und jetzt
gehen wir in den norden nach hamburg
dort ist johannes prag am telefon
verbracht sein sie gegrüßt und wir sind
gespannt auf ihre anmerkung ja meint
hamburgs guten tag in die runde es wurde
besprochen von der positionierung die
man von den muss als europa hat wieder
auf seiten der usa oder china und mich
würde interessieren
in die runde gefragt wie das denn gehen
soll im hinblick auf die eklatanten
menschenrechtsverletzungen die ein china
stattfinden einfach mal in die runde
gefragt wie soll das gehen wie soll sich
die neue bundesregierung da kann die
machen um sich da klar auf seiner seite
zu positionieren danke schön herr prag
ja also ich glaube ich denke mir zum
einen ist das schon mal eine wäre das
eine eindeutige positionierung wenn man
menschenrechte und wirtschaftspolitik
nicht voneinander trennt sondern dass
man da durchaus gewisse standards auch
festlegt die man der ball eigentlich
auch schon längst längst vorhanden sind
und sagt wenn bestimmte standards nicht
eingehalten werden dann heißt es auch
für deutsche unternehmen auch für die
deutsche automobilindustrie dass solche
geschäfte dann nicht stattfinden egal ob
sie in china statt in oder ob sie in
deutschland stattfinden ich glaube damit
wäre ein großer schritt getan dann
könnte man auch ganz ganz anders noch
mal vorgehen wie sehr sich einzelne
deutsche unternehmen dann auch von
chinesischer seite erpressen lassen also
sich dann auch dann anzuschauen ok wenn
bestimmte dinge
bestimmte menschenrechtsstandards
arbeitsstandards nicht eingehalten
werden dann können solche unternehmen
wie vw ein kein werk in der zehn young
in der uiguren-region erregen ich glaube
ein weiterer schritt und ich glaube das
ist hier wiederum jetzt umgekehrt
gedacht ist wenn man man muss noch mal
auch auf seine eigene
wettbewerbsfähigkeit schauen und zu
gucken wie man bestimmte technologien
die man als wichtig erachtet da sind die
usa und china im grunde vorbilder also
dass eine gewisse schlüsselindustrie
netzwerktechnik und so weiter dass man
auch sagt okay da machen wir uns weder
von china noch von den usa abhängig
sondern sorgen dafür dass solche
technologien dann hier in die auf diesem
kontinent geschaffen und produzierte und
hergestellt werden können ich glaube
auch dass sie wäre ein wichtiger aspekt
um nicht erpressbar weder von den usa
noch von china zu sein eine ergänzung
machen darf aber kurz war möglichst
viele zu nähren dass in der superbike
wie interessiert offenbar das publikum
hier in deutschland an solchen wichtigen
fragen ist also ein wahlkampf gerade das
verbot nicht glauben aber um noch vor
unserem publikum das ist eine ergänzung
und dahinter etwas ergänzen es gibt nur
einen weg wie man das erreichen kann
indem man enger zusammenarbeiteten haben
wir ein geschlossenes und da darf ich
auch polen und ungarn gleich mitnehmen
das ist eine meiner größten
enttäuschungen angela merkel sie hat
zehn jahre lang zugeschaut wie viktor
orban die union und ihre länder vor sich
her getrieben hat sie hat nie wirklich
interveniert sind immer schön geredet an
die an die grundrecht erinnert aber sie
ist nie in den infight gegangen mit
orban das heißt auch auf diesem gebiet
ich glaube dass wir lernen müssen dass
europäer dass wir uns zusammenschließen
müssen dass wir nicht so viel zeit haben
in der welt mit all diesen problemen das
ist bei uns ein eintrag das wollte ich
nicht sagen von matthias rehfeld den
würde ich gerne an sie weitergeben wäre
eine solche wie wir sie gerade
diskutiert haben stärker
werteorientierte außenpolitik
deutschlands
international willkommen speziell bei
den verbündeten ja auf jeden fall ich
glaube die wertekompass in deutschland
ist schon in ordnung und wie gesagt das
war eine sehr interessante antwortet
ihnen gegenüber manchmal auf vergisst
man die wohl die werte wenn es um
wirtschaft geht in deutschland das
wirtschaft vor aber deutschland hat eine
sehr gute werte komplex und das ist
natürlich was uns alle verbindet die
hier
investieren und hoffentlich wird die
nächste deutsche regierung diese
kompetenz genauso haben wir die letzte
regierung wir gehen doch mal nach
hamburg dort ist martin macker am
telefon hermann k ja einen wunderschönen
tag in die runde man frage oder meine
besorgnis fiel dadurch dahin
globalen verteidigungsausgaben meiner
auffassung nach mit eigentlich
hieß es dann wieder in die verhinderung
der abschmelzenden polkappen gestellt
werden müssen denn 60 meter das wasser
bei weltweit ansteigt dann kann sich
jeder leicht ausrechnen was das für
dieses planeten bedeutet abgesehen von
dem feuer gründen laut teilen und immer
noch
dass deswegen liebe ich deutschland ist
es so pazifistisch hier die romantische
welt und schade dass die ganze welt
nicht so friedlich sein sollte wie die
deutschen die haben die lehre aus der
vergangenheit sehr gut gelernt aber
leider ist die welt eine gefährliche
holt mit viele schlechte aktuellen und
die welt ist leider nicht durch sein es
gibt wirklich gefahren und alles was sie
gelernt haben dass der 50 jahren ist
eine starke beteiligung eine starke
bereitschaft sich über beteiligung ist
eigentlich sehr friedens erhalten und
hoffentlich können die deutschen das
auch lernen wenn das nicht wirklich
kurze ergänzung 2013 ist der
außenminister aus polen gekommen hat
eine rede in deutschland gehalten hat
gesagt was uns was gefährlich ist dass
deutschland keine verantwortung nimmt
und nicht dass deutschland eine
verantwortung nimmt auf der globalen
ebene messen ist konstanzer lungo am
telefon ich glaube das passt auch ganz
gut was jetzt kommt die runde ich bin
auch
strukturiert werden zum beispiel
bei prozent da hat dann diese etage die
kriege zb irak wo mit einer lüge einwand
zerstört wurde und
bei allem respekt aber meiner meinung
nach
versagt selbst mit eigene außenpolitik
und sogenannte
verteidigungspolitik terrorismus und da
finde ich unverschämt weil usa quasi
zerstört europa darf mit flüchtlinge
aufnehmen und die entwicklungshilfe
dankeschön frau logo das hätte ich jetzt
nicht da es vom deutschen punkt des
präsidenten gehe aus seiner rede bei der
uno er hat gesagt in bezug auf nach
afghanistan und aus der
sicherheitspolitik wir müssen ehrlicher
klüger aber auch stärker werden und dann
hat er hinzugefügt deutsche und
europäische außenpolitik darf sich nicht
aus recht haben beschränken weniger
selbst sendungsbewusstsein mehr
offenheit und lösungswege suchen mit den
partnern
dankeschön wir gehen nach duisburg das
schaffen wir noch joachim nehring ist
telefon handy ring kurze anmerkung zu
unserer diskussion bitten ihre
eingangsfrage ganz toll an die
französische seite sind die frau die
zusammen den makro einen schweren würde
wenn ihr heute wählen könnt ihr in
deutschland sie hatte weise natürlich
die beiden hauptkandidaten laschet und
das so genannte frage von mir vielleicht
etwas nachließen der wäre auch
vorstellbar gewesen dass ich der makro
die dritte kanzlerkandidatin frau bär
wolf eingeladen hätte um ihre position
zu erfahren insbesondere zumal das auch
im hintergrund jetzt geplatzte uhr
busgeschäft ist ja anlass genug gewesen
wäre weil der brüskierung in der stadt
gefunden haben
wir müssen die zeit nutzen damit frau
sie fuß anno noch kurz antworten kann
also ich hatte den elyséepalast
angerufen und sie haben gesagt formell
muss die person fragen ich möchte den
präsidenten sehen das hat sie nicht
gemacht aber frau bock und herr beck
haben im makro in berlin
sie haben zusammen gegessen abend
gegessen vor ein paar monaten während
des frühlings also interessant das
wussten sie noch nicht
auf einen presseclub nachgefragt kann
man noch interessante informationen
unter kolleginnen und kollegen
austauschen vielen dank an die runde
vielen dank für die beantwortung der
fragen unseres publikums das war nämlich
der presseclub nachgefragt auf phoenix
und auf wdr 5 ich bedanke mich sehr
herzlich auch bei ihm für ihr interesse
wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen sonntag
ist wahltag nutzen sie ihn die sonne
scheint machen sie es gut und
hoffentlich bis zum nächsten mal und
schüssen
[Musik]